red flags of a distribution deal red
flags of a distribution deal safe one of
the toughest for last sorry actually you
know actually maybe not because when I'm
so a lot of the pictures I do are home
entertainment titles nothing to say
pictures that'll go too
theatrical if they do they'll go limited
theatrical and I think a lot of times
when I look at a contract yeah I'm
looking at the marketing and how much
they're saying the marketing is gonna
cost a lot of the distributors that I
try to avoid are these are these guys
that putting their contracts that well
they're gonna spend fifty or
seventy-five thousand dollars or a
hundred thousand dollars on PA and
marketing and I'm like well what exactly
you're gonna spend that money on because
to get the guy the average guy just
walking down the street to see your
movie it's like you need five million
dollars minimum I mean you need huge
amounts of PA just to get that random
guy walking down the street to even know
what your movie is I mean the amount of
money it takes to market billboards and
bus shelters and bus sides and TV spots
and online and getting that banner on
IMDB on the front it cost millions
millions of dollars to do a campaign
wide enough to really draw those kind of
eyeballs Home Entertainment is such a
different beast it's a lot of it's done
through now social media through free
publicity getting interviews and junkets
with your actors or getting reviews
written up and that sort of thing or you
know throw their creative non expensive
forms of marketing like for example you
know when you go into Xbox or Netflix
and it says you might also like and lyft
getting high up on that algorithm where
your film is listed with some big film
you might also like this little film
that means so much more to a smaller to
a smaller film or just getting you know
an end cap in Walmart is a huge that may
not cost you a lot do that but if you
have a distributor that has a
relationship that can do that that's
what happened with ninja apocalypse we
got an end cap in Walmart and in Best
Buy and that didn't cost anything extra
that was but that was sort of smart you
know distributor using relationships and
things that's how you have to get your
film no premiering at a really festival
it's got you know really good
promotional
sponsorship and and press behind it we
premiered ninja pocalypse at comic-con
in San Diego perfect right instead of
spending millions and millions of hours
you have it's more things like that that
I look for so when I see a distribution
contract that says oh we're gonna spend
$75,000 in marketing like on what what
are you spending that on well we've
gotta cut trailers like I can cut a
trailer I can get cut trailer cut four
grand what else well yeah I could do
posters I'm like same thing I mean I
have designers it can do poster I would
rather do those things and instead of
having the distributor bill some
enormous markup and a lot of times if
they have seventy five thousand dollar
marketing expense built in you're not
gonna see any money until that seventy
five thousand is recouped it's not like
they're gonna say well we've only spent
ten of it so okay we'll start cutting
you checks now no they're gonna keep
saying oh well you know we haven't hit
that seventy five thousand dollar
marketing cap so I really look at you
know that number how much they're
spending and it should be a smaller
number and I want to know honestly what
it is I want it to be something we
actually have a chance at making some
getting a recruitment here and not you
have to you know you have to make
seventy five or a hundred Rand before we
even see the first dollar because on a
million dollar picture I mean it's not
you're not gonna be out there in
theaters you know making thirty million
dollars so the economics are different
and how that money has been spent is
difference so things like going to fill
markets that's a reasonable justifiable
distribution expense and then marketing
expenses you know you know there's
there's certain you know cut cutting
trailers can be reasonable as long as I
know you know okay what they're spending
I like to usually have the ability to
approve any expense over a certain
amount so I know that they're not being
unreasonable you know and then there
could be you know working meals lunches
with buyers things like that are
reasonable but up to a certain amount so
so I'm usually looking for that number
to be you know curtailed somewhat and
then in terms of the term of the
distribution contract a lot of times you
know seven years this is pretty standard
but they're you know very you know I
would almost never do anything in
perpetuity you know and then sometimes
you see contracts over ten years or 12
years that might
that seemed a little excessive terms of
fees you know but for me I'm kind of
looking around the 20% range in terms of
what I'm willing to pay a distributor
some charge as much as 30% or more so
you know you know red flags to me are
typically you know term fees marketing
expenses are the first and then you know
other than that you're just looking at
sort of any onerous language that ties
you to something you don't want to be
tied to like oh we want rights to a few
to all the future sequels or something
and you know unless you're willing to
invest money in those future sequels I
mean we're only talking about this
picture you know right here so so yeah
and and then you know I think you can
tell reputable distributors to just by
the language of our contracts a lot of
times too if you little things like if
you start to see a lot of like typos and
spelling mistakes and grammar mistakes
and this is a distributor not familiar
with to me that's a red flag because any
legitimate distributors gonna have a
legitimate Attorney drafting those
contracts I don't want to see them
riddled with mistakes I typically don't
deal with distributors that I've never
heard of usually they come to me by way
of someone who I know who's worked with
them or I you know they've been around
for a while I know their work and I
tried so I try to stick with with
distributors that I already know have a
good reputation I already know people
have worked with them I've said good
things about them so I don't have to
worry about a lot of those a lot of
those issues
you